james sorry to cut you off yeah god my
parents used to make me iron
everything i don't think you
get it i don't think
all right welcome guys to another
episode of your second favorite podcast
in the world yeah man second biggest
um rogan's killing it and stressing me
out but
reagan we're coming you know we're
really they're coming we're coming for
you
yeah you guys you're helping us crush it
and um
we've decided yeah what is it gonna be
end of obviously
we've been talking for a very long time
about quitting our jobs oh yeah and we
just had a little board meeting
and uh what's it gonna be december 20
december 2021
would be our last december as working as
working
or working for the man basically we want
to work for ourselves by
january 2022 yeah bro so we're giving
ourselves 13 months
13 months certain times yeah we're going
to be working full time for you guys so
you guys literally yeah man we're
excited we're excited uh and if you guys
want to help us get there sooner then
please do please do patreon
yeah so patreon guys a new episode drops
tomorrow
look out for that one um you know what
it is three months
three months three pound a month and uh
you guys can have this uh
uncensored content um
as of january there's gonna be two
episodes a week um a
as well so guys look forward to that and
um speaking of
dropping tomorrow we have our brand
new merch line smg merch season two
drops
tomorrow tomorrow i'm sorry tomorrow
we've uh teamed up with a sick
flipping designer um called ellis he has
given us some insane designs um all
based on your guys favorite episode so
jump into that um that drops tomorrow
and we're going to be doing a merch
giveaway of course
which also starts tomorrow it's also
starting tomorrow yeah that's going to
last a week so all the details on that
were going to be in
in the description description it's
going to be on instagram yeah on twitter
so follow us on all mediums if you don't
already to be here if you want to be
part of yeah just to let you know guys
if you want to be part of the giveaway
you have to obviously be part of either
our twitter or instagram
yeah so just jump on there um
basics g if you don't have an instagram
use your friends
because it's basically that or a twitter
just use your use your mum's whatever
um so yeah without further ado um
let's do it let's do an ff hashtag fun
fact
hmm in the year 1891 the state of
chicago
challenged all their engineers to build
a structure that would be better than
the eiffel tower
the winnie engineer proposed a giant
rotating wheel
that would lift visitors high above the
city the inventor's name was george
ferris
gang pretty cool right
oh gang i think when i was a kid i
usually actually used to think like why
it's called a ferris wheel
a ferris wheel george ferris
invented the ferris wheel in 1881 did
you 1891
18 it was originated in the state of
chicago
so chicago decided they wanted to make
something that's better than the eiffel
tower yeah
why i don't know i don't know but i feel
like it's great because
the eiffel tower the eiffel tower sorry
is only in france
and obviously like there's like the
replica one in in vegas that the the
mini paris whatever did the buy have one
as well no
yeah don't think they've got it don't
think it's in africa okay um but
ferris wheels are everywhere they are
everywhere so i feel like they're
literally just got one up yeah he
smashed it he smashed it the variables
are everywhere have you ever been on the
um what's it called
the one in london london eye london yeah
i've been on it once it's actually
pretty cool is it it's actually pretty
[ __ ] it takes like an hour no
i think less than that i don't think it
takes an hour maybe 30 to 45
maybe maybe it's actually pretty cool
yeah i've never been on it
every time i've it's a good it's a good
like touristy thing to do yeah every
time i've been
touristing in um london yeah
i just i see it and then i see the queue
the queue is jarring
yeah i went sorry to cut you off i went
on a date
um that's when i went on it it was it
was a date this was obviously when i was
living in london this was
i want to say eight years ago maybe
seven
between seven and nine years ago this
was time ago um
yeah i don't remember like how the queue
was in blah blah but it wasn't that
expensive
with your ticket ting and then you can
you can either
um book out the whole thing for yourself
like the the pod
okay for you and whoever and you can
like people propose on there people do
so much stuff
like you can speak people bang
i bet people bang on there a cheeky
sloppy top are you at the top you're at
the top rags
is there cameras in there do you think i
i want to say yes
i want to say yes i don't know but i
want to say yes
i would feel like that would be good
yeah yeah still though
james is a view at night it's a view
it's a view
no wonder yeah yeah people must get
sloppy top on there because yeah rags i
think as well because i've never
probably the main reason as well is
because i've never actually um
[Music]
for some reason i've never done tourist
stuff in
london in the summer okay always in the
winter
okay and it's freezing and every image i
have of the
london eye is literally me looking
at the queue freezing my tits off and
i'm like [ __ ] that i'm not doing that
[ __ ] that
i'm not doing it to go up in the sky nah
i'm good i'm literally good
like yeah no i'm not doing it but yeah
it seems like something i don't know
have i missed it nowaday
no it's everlasting man like it's not
the the what's the word i'm looking for
the novelty the novelty of it's not
gonna wear off
yeah it's not gonna wear off like i've
like i said i've not i've been on it
once and that was probably like between
seven and nine years ago i can't
remember
yeah yeah yeah and if i go with it again
i'll probably be gassed again you know
what's mad that speaks because i i can
imagine a lot of people who aren't from
england would be keen to go on it oh
yeah of course
but um obviously i've never gone in it
i've been to london
three thousand times and um
i remember when i was in school i had a
canadian history teacher
in my gcc history uh don't ask me why i
took history for gcc
gcc history i dropped after the first
year i'm terrible after year 10 i
dropped it
terrible they had i remember i had a
counselor sit me down at the end of year
10 and was like
james really are we sure do you really
want to continue this
it's torture for everyone firm that's
people and i was like lock it
lock it you know why though because dice
i digress i'll get back to the main
point
yes anymore our head of history yeah was
a guy called mr body
mr body yeah and he was so intense with
his his
he loved history and he you know how
i like to tell stories and even if it's
like a mundane story i'd like to i
i can see myself there like yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's how he did every lesson
with history if he was telling you a
story
about history like you were in it that's
a good thing though great yeah yeah
he's not the history teacher i got okay
okay okay i was thinking where's the
story
oh yeah yeah i remember we had a parents
evening in year nine so you picked jesus
for year ten eleven right
year nine and i remember thinking raw
i'm actually so loving history right now
but no i didn't tell anyone about it
yeah and i remember i sat down with him
i didn't tell anyone about it
yeah he was crushing it and i remember
yo history's actually sick
yeah uh mr body's like a sick history
teacher and i was in that time in my
life where you know when you're watching
like um
really lame shows like saved by the bed
and stuff like that
where there's that one teacher that they
just gravitate to and then always talk
about oh did you ever have that one
teacher that really changed your life
and i used to watch fresh prince all the
time and i think there's a little bit of
fresh prince where he had a teacher that
really like changes the game for him
i can't remember but i feel like his
fresh prince or something around one of
those shows okay where there's just like
a typical
student who's like a flunk yeah and he
thinks school is [ __ ]
and then he finds that one teacher who
changes the game that's the era i was in
my life
and then we went to parents even i sat
down with uh mr boddy and he was selling
um
history to me but at the same time he
was looking at me like
i'm wasting my breath even trying to
sell it to you because i can tell you
don't give a damn about
history and i remember thinking nah i
you're making me give a damn my dad was
there obviously with me and i'm thinking
it would be nice to me for me to pick a
subject that my dad actually might think
oh okay
rather than like pe obviously picking i
remember going to the pt
table and i basically just like spotted
my teacher i was like you know
yeah yeah you know i'm here man sat down
with james
[Laughter]
that conversation lasted about 30
seconds jokes that's
jokes but yeah history i remember
thinking you know what i'm actually
going to sign up history and i signed up
for art which is another one
that no one but i was actually sick art
at the time i was i wasn't sick i was
decent
i think i got a b an r or a c yeah i got
a b in the end
b or c only because my coursework was
trash my coursework was trash
i remember they gave us this fat
sketchbook and they were like
if you want a chance of passing this
sketchbook needs to be full by the time
you're done
and i'm thinking i've got time for that
i'm trying to play football
who's got time to fill out a sketchbook
and i remember my boy filled out his
entire sketchbook
cover to cover with sick stuff like his
pages were so crinkled by the end of it
that he's been working i remember
thinking raw there's levels to this
there is there's less there's levels of
art
yeah i might but my remember my final
piece was live well i think my phone
calls
mine was a it was like a collage thing
yeah mine was what was my final piece it
was because remember they give you like
10 hours right yes
they sit there and you've got 10 hours
and i remember 10 hours to do this thing
bro i'll smash out in four um
i mean mine was a parrot it's so random
there's a parrot
i and i did it with acrylic paint uh
and i remember like i'd only learned the
technique
for this painting um like a week before
i remember we were doing uh because we
get something like i think the topic was
like nature
so you had to do pictures to do with
nature and stuff
so i picked like all these birds and
[ __ ] ironically because i hate birds
at the time i don't know why i picked
birds but yeah i had this like
uh parroting and i remember i was doing
something for my coursework the week
before
and um i was using watercolors and i
thought oh for parrots like watercolors
and the blends and stuff that's gonna
look like japanese sick
i remember my teacher at the time our
teacher came over she was like oh have
you ever
done it in acrylic and i remember
thinking
no why would i do it in acrylic that's
just bold nastiness
and like you can't blend acrylic like
that acrylic is very like
blotchy kind of stuff and um she was
like nah nah nah like there's like
finesse to a critic if you want to do it
and she remembers i remember she got the
thing and she was literally
painting it as if she would sketch so
like little lines
and it was like bang bang bang bang bang
bang and the
the i remember the intensity of the
different colors from like the white of
the face
to like the orange of the beak to like
the green and everything like that that
she was doing on this parrot i've been
thinking
blood clot that looks sick she did like
one wing or whatever he looked banging
and i was like yo
and i just spent every day for the next
week just practicing this thing that
you've done
so when i actually did my parrot i don't
want to blow my trunk it looked like a
real parrot
i remember i had literally a a picture
phone
at the time you could literally take it
was one of the first phones you could
take pictures yeah yeah yeah
it was probably a nokia yeah it was a it
was a samsung
flip but it flipped that way do you
remember so it didn't flip
open you could take it to the side and
it would at a circle screen you could
decide it went up like that
i know exactly what our camera was cool
i can't remember exactly what it was
i think it was a i think it was a
samsung um but anyway yeah yeah i got
that
and then i remember sending a picture to
my dad
that was when um monster media texts mms
mms used to cost like 50 50 to be a pop
mms was so expensive and there was no
there there was no 2g 3g
4g nothing nothing back then these lot
were born into this yeah
lucky bro so yeah my dad and mum's like
i remember my dad sending me a picture
back like why are you sending me a
picture of a pirate
and i was like that's my art piece and
he was like i thought that was a parrot
i thought that was a parrot dick and i
was like gang and i got i think i've got
an a star for that one
nice but um
i nearly got uh nothing for it because i
did the parrot yeah
and i was so guessing the pirate
probably looked amazing but it literally
took like six hours to do it
and i remember thinking my hands hurt
and i'm tired so uh i would just left it
like that
and then the teacher was like big man
there's no background like
there's just this parrot and then the
whole thing was white paper
she was like that's not like that looks
incredible but that's not nothing
and i was like all right cool and you
know what i'm like once i've lost
interest in something i'm done with it i
did the most childish
sunset i literally did like the corner
to the corner
with the rays coming down she went nuts
oh she did she came over she screamed in
my face when the whole class was silent
she was like you're taking the [ __ ]
piss like what is that like a
two-year-old could do that and i'm like
i can't be bothered for this bro
this is so boring now my parents live no
i'm
my parents sick i don't care about this
anymore she made me sit there and cut it
out
cut out the paper and then stick it onto
a new piece of paper
brand new background i was vex i was
solve x but um
anyway to take me back to the whole
thing yeah
history signed up for history completely
bro i know i need to stop sometime
history signed up for history because mr
body was sick
ended up getting put in with this
canadian teacher who was really nice
but he just wasn't intense with his
stories and we didn't get to learn about
anything interesting it was like the
history of medicine
that's that was our topic for that
semester history of medicine it was
beyond boring that sounds boring beyond
boring but to get me to the point this
is why i talk about the london eye
about being english and not caring about
going in london in that i'm sure a lot
of people would love to go in the london
night
and uh i remember when um i was in
history
the guy was like oh how many people have
oh no he assumed everyone in the class
had been to um
stonehenge why
because stonehenge when he described
that i remember thinking
raw when you put it that way i mean i
guess no one had been to stonehenge
and no one gave a [ __ ] about going to
stonehenge so why am i going to
stonehenge
but like if you actually think about
stonehenge is like
one of worlds isn't certainly one of the
seven wonders of the world it's a yes a
phenomenon no one knows how they got
there
no one knows everything yeah yeah yeah
yeah so
i don't even know where stonehenge is i
was gonna say i don't know where it is
but i didn't want to sound like an idiot
i don't know where it is okay i'm glad
we i think you can pass it on the
motorway though
one motorway somewhere i'm gonna google
it now yeah people say stonehenge is
a place called stonehenge but i'm gonna
i'm gonna guess
it's near
i have no idea i'm gonna guess devon
wrong waist man waist man
my eyes widened i bet they did um
it says tamara salisbury where the hell
is salsa i know james
i don't know um
i don't know but yeah it's one of them
ones where no one knows how it
got made and how the bricks are aligned
the way they're aligned and blah blah
blah
yeah bro it's oh it's salisbury is
not too far from southampton so it's
even down
it's down down down down down south okay
fair play
yeah stonehenge and he was like no one
put their hand up and everyone was like
why would i go to stonehenge and he's
like big man what do you mean
you've got one of the seven wonders of
the world in your back garden go see it
like why would you not go and see it and
i was just like
i just don't care i just don't care but
that being said at this day and age if i
because obviously i don't know where it
is if i was just driving
and i looked to my left and saw
stonehenge gassed i was screamed
do you know what i mean i would if i was
not expecting it yeah and i just looked
and i was thinking
is that is that stonehenge you'd have to
have someone with you to come down yeah
if we were there together and i was like
is that stonehenge and you're looking
like oh i think that is
i don't want the detail we'd have the
details we're doing the uv on the way
i'll be gassed gas but it's it don't you
think it's crazy that
teachers like obviously in your in what
year were you in yeah nine when they
were seven years
yeah that was it yeah obviously as a
year tencent you're not really gonna
care when you're in year ten you don't
give a [ __ ] you don't give any you don't
care you're thinking about
girl and football football and pum
that's it
that's it as an average teenage male
that's all you're thinking
there's nothing else to kill obviously
the fact that what
15 16 years later we're thinking of well
not 66 years ago
however long it was 15 yeah 14 15 years
later 14 years 14 years later
we'll be gassed if you saw stonehenge
yeah it's mad it's so crazy it is
actually mad but
to be fair i would not i would love to
see it but if i stumbled across it
oh if i wanted to try it from manny just
to go inside no no no no one can say oh
do you want to go to
stonehenge today where is it salesbury
where's that near southampton
no immediately no no there's got all
towers let's do something fun
i'm not going to see a couple of bricks
yeah i'm not i don't care i don't know
if i stumbled across it oh my god
or if for example um we were just in a
car
and we happened to be like in the
southampton area if someone was like
bro did you know stonehenge is like 20
minutes that way i immediately like
let's go let's go and see it let's go
see it yeah yeah but at the time i
didn't give a damn
i didn't give a damn did you did you do
french in gcse
hell no did you i dropped french as soon
as they let me
as soon as they let me i know that's a
lie i didn't do it in gcse i did it but
you did it
from your seventh to year nine yeah the
year 789 was your french teacher crazy
right no my french teacher wasn't
crazy but i will tell you a story about
my friend she tell me why you're going
to say this
and i'll tell you sorry about my friends
i she's pretty crazy now but yeah
it's funny thing because mine was a
woman as well okay she's nuts
um my i only ever did french in year
seven because obviously i moved to
nigeria from
eight to ten so i didn't i didn't do
french in nigeria but i don't know
anything did you just do english they
did english
they did all the subjects but i think
they did all the subjects bar languages
oh okay cool
um so wait i did french in year seven
and i can't for the life i don't
remember her name but i know exactly
what she looks like
oh she's like a middle-aged white woman
curly hair she's english but she studied
in france okay i can't remember her name
but she used to get so tell a lie we did
do french nigeria
because i remember one of my friends was
doing as well
she was the most
aggravated woman i can i can ever
picture at that time in my life you know
what i mean she was so frustrated that
we weren't getting it yeah and the fact
that the thing is i can't even remember
specific examples but i know when i
pitch it when i
remember the language french and i
picture this woman's face all i see is
anger
all i see is anger she had no patience
she always raised her voice and she
always used to get red because she was
so heated all the time because there's a
white woman she'd get
red in the face mm-hmm she'd scream at
us
obviously no one cared about that's
because yeah they're fixed but no one
gives a damn about their subjects
if it's not like maths english and
science like because you have to pass
those
i don't care bro no it's not pe i don't
care bro i used to ride for pe
no one could i was so excited for pe all
the time every week
here we go bro it was it was gang um
yeah my french teacher she was a um
little person um so
she suffered from some element of
dwarfism i don't know what it was
she was small and she had a really
really high pitched voice
okay and she was actually french okay
her name was miss capamachio
sounds italian but okay it does sound
italian actually but yeah miss
capomachio
um she went through it
children can be cruel fam oh children
have no filter
femme so she literally sounds like this
she was like punch her children
that's what she sounded like and she was
literally like three foot five i'm
saying she was short
miss capamachio was short
and bro to this day my heart wrenches
this is so weird as well like um
so she came in i never said anything i
just want to hold my hands i never said
anything
i never made fun of her not once yeah
yeah yeah even then i was cringing when
people used to bully her yeah she used
to obviously
she had to have a special whiteboard
lowered for her
so she could write on the whiteboard and
she still had to stand on a stall or a
little stepladder to
write on the whiteboard it was torture
and everyone would just bully
the living [ __ ] out of her and she would
leave the classroom crying
and it was horrible and day after day
she got bullied from
dale i don't know why she put up with
these kids but she got bullied
day after day after day after day and i
remember
sitting um sitting with uh
my step-sister so obviously i lived in
north and my step-sister
was i lived in luton and um
she was the same age as me so she went
to a high school in luton
and then we were just talking one day
about subjects and stuff
and then um this is dread she uh we were
sitting talking talking talking and i
was
i was we talked about french and i was
like oh yeah man like french is long et
cetera et cetera and i was like to be
fair we're not even learning anything
because we've got this like new teacher
she's just come to our school and she's
like she's getting bullied every day
and um she's like a like i decide i
think at the time i called like a [ __ ]
i was like she's just like a [ __ ] and
like she got really high voice
and then she was like miss capamachio
and i was like what and she was like
she got bullied out of our school that's
why she's at your school
because she got bullied i lived an hour
away from her
she's uh she's not even like she went
from one school to the next she moved an
hour up the road
to my school coincidentally out of all
the schools
she moved from my sister's school to my
school and she was like yeah we ran her
out at school
we ran her out of that school
i wasn't expecting you'd say that bro
she said we ran her out of this school
and i was like you man are disgusting
you men are [ __ ] disgusting and
yeah as far as i don't know she made it
in a school either
she probably didn't she definitely
didn't damn that's so peak bro
speaking of teachers i had an english
literature teacher
i can't remember left me she was uh she
was small she wasn't like she didn't
have any like um dwarfism or anything
she was just a short woman yeah
short white woman but she was so
annoying everyone hated her
everyone hated her yeah because she was
just such an [ __ ] yeah
um and i feel like sometimes some
teachers just don't know how to
they can teach but they don't have to
teach children yes do you know what i
mean yes you might be a good teacher but
just
hate kids they just hate they can't
teach children they can't there's no
balance
so we weren't warm to her but there was
one day
we came i think we had english lit maybe
twice a week i can't remember i don't
know how it works
yeah i can't remember how it worked but
we went into the class
and she had a black eye and we were like
what the f even though we we didn't like
her as a person yeah yeah yeah
we don't want to get in domestic teacher
do you know what i mean he's like what's
going on yeah
everyone's asking what she's like oh she
got mugged on the way home last night
they stole her bag
everyone was ready to ride out there
that day it was mad
i remember like it was yesterday yeah
like what miss what
my teacher show me where it was at every
everyone is ready for it
this is like 11 30 midday yeah 11 30
yeah yeah we've got
we've got school the mugs of god by the
way
they've spent the cash in there you were
ready to ride out for her it was mad it
was such a weird
turn of events yeah dynamic yeah that is
kids are dumb that's
kids are stupid they're one of those
ones that's like you know when you see
like um
movies and stuff and they're like ah
there's like could be like an older
sibling yeah who bullies
yeah is getting bullied by someone else
and they come in with that no one slaps
my little brother but me
that's the teacher no one thumps up my
teacher but me yeah that makes no
sense it makes noise kids will ride out
for any kind of
any kind of beef i remember
[Laughter]
i remember learning the dynamics of
racial hatred in school okay so like
this is a weird one as well
i remember this is so weird like
we were um we were in
english class i remember and like for
some reason these asian dudes
um like broke into our school they were
a bit older so they're probably like
i don't know if i was in year i must
have been in year nine
so i'm like 13 14 and they must have
been 17 18 19 whatever
and for some reason they broke into it
like jumped the gate on our school and
they're in like we had a big car park in
the middle of our school
and then like the buildings went like
around were like designed around it and
stuff they came in the middle
these asian dudes and they just started
jumping on like the teachers cars and
stuff and the bonnets and they would
start waving to us in the thingy
so we were like same thing defensive
like yo come with my teachers cardboard
like i said i'm gonna yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah all the managers go
mad at these dogs yeah yeah yeah who's
these my comments what's up
my school class my teacher
come off his car bruh i swear that if i
have to come down and say this long
chatting the most chat in the most oh my
days so yeah
i'm we're chatting all sorts of the
windows and these when i go nuts
and there's a little asian girl um in
your class in our class indian girl
called shannon
she was lovely and then uh she was like
oh what do they look like she couldn't
even like she couldn't bother to get up
she's like
that and i was like i don't know like
they're just like these asian dons
and she was like ah i bet they're
[ __ ] packies
and at that time in my life i didn't
know the difference between an indian
person and a pakistani person
i knew the difference but i didn't
understand that there was any kind of
animosity
yeah yeah yeah yeah whatever yeah yeah
yeah i didn't understand what she was
telling me about she was
there i mean my boy stopped i feel like
what is she just saying
[Laughter]
she was up in a [ __ ] bag he's like
[ __ ] baggies and i was like
[Music]
that was you yeah yeah in my head like
obviously i didn't write i would never i
never used
to call people that word ever yeah yeah
yeah yeah i don't think i've ever
not even to like blow my hand or
anything like that but i don't think
i've ever used a racial slur for anyone
in my life
apart from obviously like the n word um
i don't think i've ever used a racial
survey on anyone
and for some reason racial slurs really
annoy me um but anyway
i digress so yeah she's dropping the
p-bomb yeah non-stop
and i'm like to my point like i'm so
confused
what is going on like shannon's going
off yeah he's asian you know
sam's going off and he's asian and i'm
like
i don't know you pulled it to one side
shannon love i don't want to
tell you how to live your life but
what's going on with this
you know how your mum talks to her
friends like what's what's going on
what's that about like i was like
you do know that you're what you mean
and she's like immediately she was like
i'm what
and i'm like no no i don't think i don't
i don't think i don't this is my point
it's just that you used it and they're
like i know i i can't use it because i'm
not you know
i'm not indian i'm not pakistani but um
like you seem to use it quite radio
derogatory against your own you know
and she's like big man are you calling
me like a baggy and i'm like
no no i'm not i'm not i'm not i'm not
calling you
but i'm just saying you seem to be quite
angry at those ones and you keep
he's you're using that she's like i'm
indian and i was like
i know i know that i know you are and
she was like they're pakistani
and i was like oh
and even at that point it's how dumb i
am
i didn't even know i'm not 13. even at
13 i
i didn't even relate um
the slur [ __ ] as short for pakistan i
didn't even relate the word packet to
pakistani
i just knew it was a racial racial slur
slur
for whatever the derogatory right yeah
derogatory stuff for someone
asian that's what i thought yeah because
anyone of that
race at that era in that era will
automatically call that world yeah
and he didn't i never realized like not
only
this thing as well then i realized that
ra it's actually
long for indian people yeah because not
only are they do they get racial slurs
they get racial says that don't even
relate to them yeah yeah yeah because
everyone would just score them with that
because
and it's just like imagine like at the
time as well this is
i guess interestingly enough as well
probably growing up in london you
probably
saw this a lot more than me but and we
never really had
well where i grew up we never really had
too many like um
asian in terms of like um oriental asia
kind of like chinese
okay japanese korean we never really had
any
really asians like that and we just had
indians like yeah yeah what is it what
is it eastern
what's more in terms of like
direction west if we're talking asia
asia west asia is like he's like china
blah blah blah oh
east asia i'm assuming it's like india
i thought it was the other way around i
could be completely wrong i thought was
the other way around i thought east
asian was
kind of china japan career and then pull
up a map
story continuing story yeah so anyway we
never really had any in my um
school so like kind of like [ __ ] bombs
and stuff like that
we're never going off um
but then again like i it took me like a
couple other years to then realize that
when people are getting caught i think
i'm right
you're right this yeah because japan is
at the end this is west knope
or no
[Laughter]
that's jokes and i remember yeah east
yeah we never had really anyone from
east asia yeah
it makes sense yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
but i'm assuming london probably had a
lot more
i'm assuming i'm assuming yes but my
school no
oh okay cool my school my school was a
very very
black slash uh
european dominated school mine was
mine was quite a mix apart from east
asia as well
yeah apart from east asia we had quite a
big mix
so white english
a lot white european a lot somewhere
yeah we had where
where i grew up we had a lot of like
warehouses and stuff
so like easy jobs for like polish people
and stuff to come and get a job
we had albanians in our school really oh
we had and i've got nothing against our
beginnings
i don't know how we had so many
albanians in our school yeah
so we had a lot of west asians
europeans white europeans and black um
but uh yeah anyway shannon was going off
with the p word bro
sean was going off with the p word and i
that was the first time i was like ra
like you india might go through it yeah
because you have p-bombs dropped to you
that don't even make sense
they don't relate to you they don't
relate to you because and then i
remember thinking about that yeah like
east asians as well if you're from korea
fam
and someone's calling you a c word and
i'm just like
imagine being a that's in that i'm not
even chinese family
different and then you can't even to
someone who's a racist you can't even
say but i'm not even chinese because
that's just get trigger for them to go
even off
you just leave it just leave it and keep
it moving it's so long it's so peak
yeah bro it is peak it actually is peak
but uh yeah that was
a weird day for me i remember thinking
shannon aren't you shannon really
i don't think you should be using that
one yeah i think you need to have a hard
look at yourself
but yeah that was a weird day boy but um
right let's get on topic i've got a fan
request
hit me so this one was
cool oh this is a nice little
introduction hello
hope you're having an amazing day god
bless uh thank you
just would be interested to know what
are your love languages
i remember seeing that you remember this
i didn't read the whole thing but i
remember seeing
that pop up um apparently your current
love language is linked to the fact that
you
didn't receive that type of love when
you were younger so you crave that type
of love now
is this true for you so when i read this
i actually don't know anything about
love languages so there's five types you
know
i've read up on them now i don't know
them words of affirmation
there's acts of service i think we spoke
i'm pretty sure we spoke about this
in the episode with jay the first step
but maybe it was the time you threw i
was sick and you were this is when i was
sick and i was gone yeah i remember
you guys did so yeah so there's
affirmation there's acts of service
those are this i can't remember the rest
cool so the ones i've got here words of
affirmation
quality time receiving gifts acts of
service
physical touch and nursing yeah yes five
yeah
cool so do you know what yours are um
read them again
so yeah just tell me if this is a yes or
no and then we'll come back okay yeah
so for you so for someone to do to me
someone to do for you yeah yeah yeah
yeah this is how you receive love yeah
so words of affirmation so stuff like i
love you and all that stuff
i'm fine with that quality time her
giving me
you guys spending quality time together
yes she's making the time just yeah i
guess yeah
yeah of course i feel like that should
be everyone receiving gifts
not really i don't really need to
receive gifts acts of service
probably acts of service acts of service
for me and physical touch
probably that as well um i feel like
it's more acts of service so for you is
acts of service
is the main one i feel like i feel like
knowing myself i felt now
knowing myself as a 29 year old male
i think more actually so you get like
you really so if you're if any yeah if
there is even a point where you
you're looking at a go and you're
thinking right i love you someone hurt
it would be her
doing something for you so the extra
service would be yeah like
doing the hoovering for you or washing
your dishes or yeah i need your clothes
or something like that just without
being asked yeah
that's something that you'd look at the
thing right actually not even
necessarily love this girl but this girl
loves me
oh okay do you know what i mean yeah
yeah yeah yeah fair play but yeah
obviously i would like
you know yeah yeah that's that's
obviously yeah that makes sense cool so
do you think
for what this person said she said are
people are saying that that's because
you never received that when you're
younger would you say that correlates to
you do you think you didn't have a lot
of
because obviously i don't know your
childhood but i do know you're a very
independent person
so i wouldn't be surprised if if you
grew up
not you telling me people didn't do that
much stuff for you you had to do a lot
of stuff for yourself
um that
that could possibly be true because
thinking about it now
i know a bad drawing about it but
obviously i went to school in andrea
blah blah blah
i all these things that not necessarily
have to fend for myself but i wasn't at
home
i haven't been at home since you're
eight that's
listen that's long saying that out loud
that's scary yeah i haven't been at home
since you're eight like
i haven't had a apart from one year in
2008
no that's a lie yeah so i've not been at
home from your eighth
to year
fema eight to the end of uni so yeah hey
yeah eight was for us to 2013 when we
graduated
i haven't been at home and then from
2013 to 2016 is when i was at home
before i mean that's 10 years i think
yeah we because yeah year 7 was 2002. i
remember that yeah
yeah it would have been 2003. so yeah
2003. 2013.
yeah jesus christ christ bro obviously
i've come back and forth back and forth
like sometimes all that stuff but yeah
like in terms of just being like stably
at home with my family
so you've been looking after yourself
since raw that's
crazy how does that make you feel saying
that out loud and relating to her
question
it makes i don't know how it makes me
feel it probably
it's probably just like a a mind [ __ ]
like a what's the word i'm looking for
uh like a light bulb not even a light
bulb like
oh like a yeah emoji yeah i can't
remember i don't know what word that is
but that head explosion
oh yeah sure yeah so it it's it doesn't
make me feel any type of way because
i've lived my life you know
i don't really care that much but it's
just like a
moment because i would never assume that
my current
act my current love language is because
it's something i didn't receive
yeah yeah yeah when i was younger yeah
yeah i would never relate the
correlation is mind-blowing
that's what i was looking for
mind-blowing the correlation is
mind-blowing to me
because it could be potentially true
because like i said for 10 years i was
necessarily fending for myself why did
you go to nigeria by the way um
that's actually a funny story so it's
not funny but it's a story
um the reason why my dad actually only
told me this
last this summer he told me this this
summer um
well like the full story anyway the
reason why we went was because
in year seven i went to a boarding
school which was in england which was in
london
in catford and i was doing 14 subjects
yeah it was a it was a it wasn't a
border school sorry it was a private
school did i say boarding school you
said boarding it was a private school it
wasn't a boarding school not bad it was
called sent dancers college in southeast
london and captain i think it was in
catford anyway
i did 14 subjects and my sister my
sister's two years older than me
so she went to a public school it was
called west norwood for girls i don't
know why i remember these
um and it got to a stage where
i all i knew was sports
okay and that's all i loved that's all i
was giving my energy to yeah i was
always good at maths yeah
just normally you are good enough but my
energy and my enthusiasm was all going
into sports
and i think it was a i think it could
have been like the end of year
parents evening kind of thing and my pop
said out of the 14 subjects
i only passed maths only past um pe
oh okay um i may have duck yeah it
wasn't yourself
i only passed mpe or whatever and he
said how is this possible how about
because
for that score he was it was he was
playing grand the term i think it was
like 5k or terminal
in dollars and i was like why am i
wasting all this money
obviously i was in year seven i don't
remember this he remembers like it was
when he told me the story
i felt i thought i was there yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
his pocket for him to remember the story
vividly
because it will probably hurt me yeah
yeah seven
yeah fourteen subjects all you can pass
is pe fourteen substitutes is a lot
though
that's a lot why are you doing that many
subjects i don't have the answers to
these questions
because that's what you should've been
asking because i remember because i
remember it must've been folks i
remember i was doing latin in year seven
no wonder you were failing fam i
remember doing latin in yourself
i was thinking oh because i was doing
french as well yeah yeah i was in french
latin obviously all the normal subjects
english lit i've seen
pr i was doing so many so many subjects
anyway p was the only one i passed and i
was like
nope spoke to marge like let's let's
take them to nigeria
um the school i went to when andrea
wasn't even the first option i think
they
figured out options barbara and then
that was it my sister obviously wasn't
at the time
meant to go it was meant to they meant
to just take me but they weren't just
going to take me so yeah
yeah yeah yeah but i was the reason why
we went so it wasn't like a let's take
the kids to nigeria and let them have
the experience it was because i was
[ __ ] up here so your family
at that time this is obviously like a
very typical
last generation two generations ago
thing is that yes they valued
education so much that they were willing
to uproot their entire life as a family
just so you
could do better in school just so i
don't mess up because they were paying
grants and all i was doing was [ __ ]
kicking
because it was a rugby school so all i
was doing was rugby oh yeah
private schools are rugby schools rugby
and hockey it was a rugby school
it was a rug how many black people is
there hardly any there's not that many
no but there was quite to be fair
actually that's a lot there was quite a
few black people because it was
southeast london oh okay yeah
um there was a actually a handful
how long did it take you to get there
everything massive um i lived in south
island
oh did you
i think it was in south west maybe and i
lived in south east
so i probably took about half an hour i
took a bus oh okay i remember okay
um so yeah anyway i
they i moved to nigeria or me and my
sister moved to nigeria because of
myself but at that time like i said
she's two years older than me so she's
in year nine she wasn't year nine at the
time i was in year seven
she was at that time doing well she's
always been academically better than me
always and always will be yeah
yeah she's very smart um she was at the
time doing well
so well i think it's in english she was
about to get her poems published
in by some this is what the story my dad
told me this summer i had never knew
she was about to get a [ __ ] published
and she was doing well in all the other
subjects at one block like it was a
great summer for her
how did it had to dip
i never knew titty told me this wow good
thing they didn't tell you that
that would have scarred you i think it i
don't know if it would have scarred me
because i don't think i would have
processed it in a sense that
i would have been able to digest the
fact that i'm ruining my sister's life
oh okay i mean because i mean yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you [ __ ]
about what you're feeling
do you know what i mean i don't think i
would have digested it i think all i all
i thought was i'm going to nigeria for
two years
and obviously i hated it at first but it
was one of the best experiences i've had
really oh yeah i would i if i never went
to nigeria for those two years i would
still haven't
um i would still have a grasp of my
heritage and all that
later on in life because we went we
visited blah blah my parents obviously
speak to me in europe
etc but school in there like being
around my peers yeah same way in any
school like you just adapt
yeah and it's it's hard to explain if
you're not
either going to a school in another
country or whatever but it just changes
you man
it changes yours but and that was my
true
my true what's the word i'm looking for
introduction to independence
yeah yeah yeah because that's that that
alone
has tailored my life because i am i
am so independent you are super
independent like that's why i'm like
moving and all that stuff i know what to
do when it comes to moving like this
17 times in my life
for those that follow me personally you
would know i just moved
not too long ago and it was one of the
most mundane exploring experiences
i want to wish you on my worst enemy
like moving is so long
but yeah that's mad so yeah that that
explains the love language thing yeah
what about yourself um
let me read them out again mine might be
the same
i feel like mine is actually service
because it's not necessarily the fact
that i am lazy i want people to do [ __ ]
for me but when people do [ __ ] for me
i'm like
gang yeah i know what i mean yeah yeah
like
so words of affirmation i don't really
need people to tell
yeah but i'm trying to think
about my whole life and have i i
definitely haven't always enjoyed
quality time
of course not i've definitely not always
enjoyed quality time like i've had
girlfriends i didn't want to be around
you know what i mean i'm a girl for
other girlfriends i'm just like any
excuse to not be around to be alone
fam i'm taking it so quality time is
definitely not one for me
yeah receiving gifts is always nice but
i don't think it's my love language
yeah i know you mean uh so acts of
service physical touch isn't is cool for
me as well
but again i've had girlfriends i'm just
like get off of me get
off don't touch me it has the acts of
service acts of service for me is
definitely like if someone cooks for me
yeah cooks me a meal or like yeah just
like does something for me if i
if i was to come home and they're like
everything's folded and nice and
like i'm just like wrong right and like
now that you're thinking about it
not like i always had to do things for
myself but my
um my mom especially
would growing up
she really wanted us to be independent
she craved for us to be independent
she didn't want us to like be helpless
at all so from
early she was teaching us
to do stuff for ourselves and like i
hated it at the time i know because
i remember you talking about when you
when your mum told you to call the
barbers for the first time
oh my god yeah i remember that story yep
oh my god so
calling the barbers for the first time
by myself um
stressful i remember my 13th or 14th
birthday
as a present i had to do all my own
ironing from now on
as a present present quotations yeah
this is like if you're 14 now you're
going to do all your yeah welcome to
adam you're gonna earn
all your own stuff from now on james
sorry to cut you off yeah god
my parents used to make me iron
everything
i don't think you get it i
[Laughter]
the thing is when this is back in the
day when obviously we all used to live
together
um obviously my sister's moved out i've
moved up so
my sister was always in charge of the
kitchen that was her yeah yeah yeah yeah
mine was hoovering and ironing bro
family
bro i can iron anything now i hate it i
used to i i used to have to eye in my
mom's bedsheets
that's long i'm not doing that i'm
thinking
i'm i'm a kid i'm 40 i'm like why are
you eyeing in bed sheets yeah bro
until this day so this day my mom would
be like oh my
god i'm not eating a thing for you i'm
not eating no bed she's not you know
what i went through as a kid
i'm not nothing my dad would tell me to
iron these boxes in these vests no
i just didn't understand the torment i
didn't understand it as a you bro but
sorry
sorry i just yeah i finally thought
about that in yeah stressful i remember
yeah 14 you're adding all your own stuff
and i was like vex um
cooking i actually enjoyed cooking so i
was fine with the cooking so we did a
lot of cooking growing
up as well um but i really enjoyed it so
that didn't really bother me but again
something that you have to do and not to
say that mom wouldn't cook for us but
yeah she wanted us to
like she wanted us to do stuff um but
chores
yeah chores chores yeah
chores in my yard growing up was like a
concentration camp
if the washing up wasn't done by the
time my mom came home from work i
finished work at a school at 3
30. it took half an hour so i used to
get home around four
yeah maybe caught past four yeah my mom
got home at
half five six bro in that period of time
with the washing up business we had to
wash up we had hardwood floors as well
so
we had to wash up we had to
mop and hoover the floors and our rooms
had to be tidy
i remember yeah i remember i wanted to
swing everyone
one time oh listen
there was a time when my stepdad was out
of work
for like a year or two so he quit his
job
i think he had like some kind of beef at
work and i think they gave him some
settlement money or something
i think someone called him a [ __ ] or
something at work and then they gave him
something something along those lines
i'm butchering i can't remember i was a
kid
but i remember he would chill at home
all day
all day i remember i'd come home from
school and i could tell this my man had
not even had a shower yet
and the yard would be a tip
the washing up is in the sink is all
from him today i'm talking breakfast
bowl
sandwich like plate like everything all
the pots and pans that he's used that
day that's the washing up that he's done
today fam
the footprints all over the hardwood
floors and stuff like that was from him
that would vex me fam crumbs all over
the floor that i have to hoover up
and i remember he would watch me rush
around like a madman getting home
making sure the hoover'd all been done
the mopping had been done
and he would just like lift his legs up
so i could do the hoof
i wanted to kill him and i'd be
scrubbing and washing up and i remember
one day one day after the whole two
years he was like oh james don't worry
about that that's that's my washing up
i'll do that and i was thinking there's
no point
i've been doing it now and there was one
time because i remember there was times
where i came home
yeah and i remember i think it was after
that day after that day
i was thinking oh okay cool so as long
as it's all his
he can deal with it that's fine because
i'm i'm not
there's there's no reason for me to be
doing this fam
i left it one day i did the hoover in
the mop and i left the washing up
my mum came home and went nuts
nuts at me nuts like i said i burnt the
house down
and i was thinking what it's my man's
staff
why am i being penalized like oh fam
it's bringing up really tormented
memories man i'm so vex thinking about
it
i am so vex thinking about it i've got
one specific memory
um so my mom um this is back when i was
living in crystal palace
which was when i was from like a kid
till year seven
i lived in crystal palace um my mum
used to work at i think like
sent thomas or king's king's hospital
king sauna it was in
central london or something and we lived
in southeast london um
so she would she used to wear black
shoes to work obviously because
there was a time where there was a
period of time where she used to tell me
to you know that that black shoe
polished china thing she's trying to
polish her shoes before she goes to work
before because she
you have to spin it around like that
yeah yeah so i remember
i think i had polished them and then
giving them to her to show them like mom
they're done so you can you can dip now
she's like
how can you give this to me when it's
they look [ __ ] like she was telling me
that it's not polished it's dirty
blah blah blah i'm thinking what are you
talking about
what are you talking about so i took the
same shoe
just walked out waited a minute and
walked back in and showed me the same
shoe
and she was like oh it looks a bit
better i think i caught her a [ __ ]
under my breath
like i think spiteful for the sake of
spite
sometimes parents just want to torment
their youths time they actually do
sometimes just just for the fun of it
sometimes they actually do i think my
mom was bored that day
i was bored that day some some things i
remember and i'm just like
why why are you doing this to me
why are you doing this to me like fam oh
my days brother i remember
i remember i got into a heat argument
one time i broke my toe
i was out with my boys and i think i've
said this before but when i was growing
up like
where my school was was like a mile and
a bit from where i lived
yes so i would have to walk in order to
play out with my boys i'm walking
like it's probably more than a maharashi
because it would be like a 40 minute
walk
that's a lot longer yeah a lot longer
than a mile so how's it actually might
not be because yeah you're gonna say
yeah walking like you can a fast mile is
like a ten minute mile right
drive no run if you're running if you
run on fast miles like 10 minutes
so if i'm walking half an hour yeah so
anyway
maybe a mile in a bit and i broke my toe
um
i tried we were playing on our bikes and
i had my boys bike
and was on the cycle path and i was
trying to do one
180 skid i remember skids i'll turn into
a 180 skid the whole thing buckled
and i landed the tire i think landed on
my all the handlebars all the time i
landed on my foot
my big toe snapped it swelled i could
feel it swelling up in my sock so bad
that i thought it was
leaking blood in my sock like it was i
the
the sensation in my foot was like oh my
[ __ ] god
like i was so scared you caught your
pierced skin or something i thought that
was going on because it was so
hot in there and i could feel it like
expanding swelling up inside and i was
thinking oh
my foot's gushing blood that's what it
felt like and i was like oh my god
and i remember crying in pain and i
bailed my mom like mom
can you please come and pick me up like
i can't walk home my foot's broke
and she's like nah i'm sure it's fine
and i'm like mom
please please and she was like i
remember she's saying something on the
lines of
who told you to go and play like a mile
away from home
like you're the one who decides to walk
up there every day so you can walk home
not big man
my foot it's broken it's broke i can't
and i remember the whole way home i'm
like
limping and i'm because i'm so upset and
vexed i'm limping harder than i need to
be yeah
like say people are watching and i'm
just there
you [ __ ] [ __ ] i don't know
you know when you're a kid and you're so
vexed and like you're like you said you
called your mom a [ __ ]
i was having such an argument and i was
just [ __ ]
[ __ ] and i remember like swinging
punches in the air
[ __ ] walk around with that so
so fast bravo oh yeah i remember i think
as a kid like why yeah no just
why there's no reason why
something when when you're a parent you
probably just
don't have patience anymore sometimes
you know what i mean
fam you just don't have patience anymore
piss off
piss off there's yeah there's some
there's some parents that like
because it's two extremes really yeah
it's hard to find a parent that's in the
middle there's two extremes like this
parents who live for their kids to the
point where it's
sickening and it just annoys the kid and
they live for their kids and they're
upset and they're always
in their kids business and they're
trying to be their kids best friend and
it's like
leave me alone that's what those are the
kind of kids that get away calling their
mama [ __ ] and stuff like that
god and then the um and then there's the
other side
which is clearly we grew up here and
they don't give a i'm not i'm your mom
i'm not your bedroom
i'm your mom i'm not your mate that's my
mum every time
i can back in the day um obviously i
don't call my parents by
their names but i can i think i used to
call my mum mummy and my dad daddy when
i was younger
yeah yeah yeah i feel like there was a
time where
i would i would speak to my parents like
i'm speaking to my boys yeah just
because
you know when you you you've not
switched it up yet yeah you've just come
home from school yeah you're still a big
gap you've still got your school yeah
i'm your mum i'm not your mate every
single time i'm like oh why are you dead
in my
eyes because this is my home i want to
feel comfortable with me
do you know what i'm saying i should be
able to speak how i won almost all the
time i'm your mom i'm not your mate ah
fam for so long
it's funny that you mentioned mum mummy
and dad daddy yeah
i remember i called my mum mum way
before i called my dad dad
i was so scared of my dad growing up i
don't know why for no reason and i
remember
i was petrified of my father fam i
remember the day i decided to stop
calling him daddy i'm just
too old now you can't keep calling him
daddy yeah and i remember
he um topped me in bed
i was at my dad's for the weekend he
taught me in bed
my son was too old to call him daddy but
the starting time was in bedford
ashley tell her i don't i don't think my
dad taught me about in my entire life i
don't know why i said chop me a bed
he put it obviously he said goodnight to
me in it so he's in my room he said good
night
bear in mind but this this is the thing
i say i'm too old i must have still
bring about
in my head i'm thinking i'm too old but
based on i know what house my dad lived
in at that time yeah
so i can't have been older than seven
okay and um
so maybe he did tuck me in yeah i don't
know i can't have been older than seven
based on the
based on the yard that i'm picturing my
dad living in yeah because it was the
first yard after he'd left like
him split up with my mum so i can't get
older than like seven but i remember
thinking like
this is the day i need to stop calling
him daddy like i'm seven i'm a grown man
yeah yeah like i can't be calling my dad
daddy out here yeah because the boys
can't see that's yeah
what the streets can't witness that
so i remember saying good night and i
was like oh i'm gonna say dad when i say
goodnight i'm gonna say dad
yeah and i remember he was walking out
the door and he grabbed the door handle
like pulled it back and i was like night
dad
and he stopped he didn't look but that
that millisecond lasted four hours i
remember he stopped
i was like good night and then just went
out and i was like thank the lord
oh god the blood would have ran from
your body
son same thing happened the first time i
told my dad i love him
because i think to this day i'm 29 years
old i think i've called my dad 11 maybe
three times i don't think i've ever told
my dad i love him
i remember the first time i said it to
my mum always i say it's one more time
i still say to my mom all the time to my
dad i think i've said it
two or three times and the first time
was exactly like the daddy time
and exactly the same position where he
i put put me in bed and stuff like that
and i remember thinking i always said i
loved your mom but i never said love to
my dad
and he put me in bed he's walking out
exactly grabbed the door again and i was
like
night daddy was like night i was like
have you my dad's response was
and then just left i thought
[Laughter]
being a kid is so long man i love you
you have to figure out so much at such a
young age
you usually do and i remember i didn't
say it again until i was in my 20s
i didn't say it again until i was in my
20s and the second time i said it
was when my dad we when this is when
we're in uni
and i was struggling fam i had no pee
and i didn't want to ask no one for help
and my dad was sending me money every
week anyway
but it was like i think it was like 20
30 pounds and obviously that's not
getting me anywhere
and i was so broke and i remember i
needed i
basically needed a heavy influx of money
to
to just sort everything out yeah do a
big food shop
pay for the gym for a month instead of
paying weekly and all this stuff like
get my [ __ ]
in order yeah i forgot you used to do
that yeah and um
so yeah i remember i remember with my
girlfriend at the time
she was like ask your dad and i'm like i
can't rav
i can't and he was she was just like
just ask your dad and i think
it must have been like two three hundred
pounds and i basically texted him and i
was like dad
i'm really really sorry but like can you
just send me like 300 pounds because
like the way i'm living right now is
just not cutting it like i just need to
do a big food shop so i've got
a long-standing amount of food yeah like
i need to pay for the gym i need to get
all this stuff sorted just so i can kind
of just breathe
yeah and then this 30 pounds a week that
you sort of mean he's actually going to
be fine yeah um
and he was like yeah mine and he sent it
to me like in the next five seconds and
she was like
right like your dad's generous and i was
like yeah he's cool and she was like ah
do you ever tell you that you love him
and i was like
i'm not telling him she was like i think
that's a big i'm not saying i'm not
telling my dad i love it afterwards
after what happened when i was five
nah
but i was i'm not turning on 11 yeah
yeah and then she was like wow you're a
waste man you're that's just sent you
three hundred pound and you're gonna say
me love him
so take someone's life love you i like
our dad i love you and then
i'm not even like thank you i know i
said i thank you for everything
um i love you okay i'll go okay and then
he takes about i love you too
and i was like oh
[Music]
matt you didn't know what's expecting it
i didn't know what to expect from i
didn't know what to do with it yeah yeah
yeah she almost
speaking of like um words of affirmation
or something like that
i've never had it from him so much that
actually made me feel weird when he said
it back
and i wanted to be like [ __ ] you gay
right he said big man said i love you
i'm sorry
bro it was weird it's mad because i
actually
i can't think of a time i've told my dad
or my dad has told me he loves me
i honest to god honestly the thing is he
probably has and i'm assuming he has but
i just can't remember
like like we said before we say it to
our moms till now do you know what i
mean so
i said to mom every single time i see
her i speak to my mom
she texts me mama the thing with my mom
i think i've told you before i don't
think i've said it on this podcast
my mum is my mum only texts me to see if
i'm alive
do you know what i mean nowadays because
i'm not i don't live there blah blah so
my mum
only texts me for a response yeah so
she'll message me in the morning for
example
hi how are you hope you're okay etc and
i'm like yeah i'd reply
and she's i'd i'd probably ask her uh so
what you're going to do with your day if
she said she's off for example
what are you going to do with your day
more time she'll air me
you know what i mean yeah because she
knows i'm alive i'm well i'm doing what
i need to do she's fine with that yeah
yeah so
yeah it's it's weird it's weird
parent-child relationships are always
weird until now to think that you can be
a grown adult and still have a weird
thing with like your parents
yeah super dodgy is is is
it is man [ __ ] it really is i can't just
i can't describe it
i feel like everyone knows what you're
talking about because everyone of of
course unless you're an orphan or you
don't have or your single parent blog
there's always something
and then but then stuff when i hear like
obviously when bella's talking about
like oh i've spoken to my mom about sex
and all this time i'm like
that's comfortable i'm not talking to my
mama any form of penetration no
way any form of penetration no way not
even oral
no way i remember one time this wasn't
actually even that long ago my mom
a couple years ago my mom um bought a
new bed so my mom still has my bedroom
as is yeah yeah um she's decorated in
her own way
um because like she's taking down like
my posters and all that stuff she's
decorated the way she wants it but she
wants to put a new bed in there
okay um it must have been like a year or
two ago yeah so she bought this new bed
and she was like i want my
she asked me and my brother to come
around and sort out okay i was livid
but whatever so we came there and then
um
i got there first and i remember because
when i moved to uni
my brother took over my room yes for the
years yes yes yes yes i remember
so the i was i remember saying why are
you getting a new bedford like what's
the point
and she was oh this one's broken and
stuff like that she's like oh the slats
are cracked underneath and that she was
like
probably because when your brother was
up there with his his first girlfriend
called
what's called anne it was probably
because when laurence and anne were up
there
and i was like what she was like yeah
you know when they were up there like
um when when they when he used to have
that room and i remember thinking
that's disgusting why are you talking
why are you talking to me about this
i'm so happy she wasn't talking about me
yeah yeah yeah yeah i remember thinking
why are you talking to me yeah yeah it's
weird
like i'm your son i'm not your mate you
know what i mean
it's the same thing don't talk to me
about my brother's sex habits
that's disgusting i'm your son i'm not
your mate
bro that's jokes mad mad yeah weird
relationships boy
i don't know how she when yeah when
better said that i was like what
like that's comfy bro that is very
confident there needs to be some kind of
formalities with the parents
but i don't want that to be with my kids
i hear that i do hear that i of course i
do hear that
but yeah it's it's just so weird it's
different generations it's different
yeah yeah yeah it depends like it all
depends on its weight as well because
yeah
it all depends on what your parents grew
up like
the parents they become will always be a
combination of
how their parents were and also the
opposite of what
they what their parents were to them
because specifically i remember growing
up so
i think i've said this before like my
mom always told the story of her like
when she was a teenager because my
grandad
was on like benefits and stuff he
wouldn't let my mom get a job
okay because it would affect his
household income and how much benefits
okay so he would not let her get a job
so my broke as a teenager okay so all
she wanted to do was have a job and get
money
okay she was so vexed that she couldn't
get a job okay so then when i was
growing up
she made me get a job and i was so she
went to the complete opposite extreme
and was like you need money you need to
have a job
and i'm thinking i don't give a damn
about money i hate you know me i hate
jobs
i don't want a job like i'd rather be
broke than have to get a job for money
that i don't even want
like in my head i'm like what's the
point so now i know when i
when my kids come to me and they like
i'm gonna be again the polar opposite
obviously i'm not gonna stop my kids are
getting a job
but i'm not gonna push them to get a job
yeah whatsoever so like from generation
to generation change it's just ping pong
ping-ponging it's weird mum yeah it is
weird [ __ ] weird
but um anyway do you want to do them on
the other side of the arsenal yeah
all right story tell your parents you
love them guys literally
tell your parents you literally love
them you never know they might stay back
oh so i'd love to know how my dad felt
when he when i actually said that
he was like what [ __ ] you gay
right that's jokes
[Music]
don't forget guys new merch drops
tomorrow
um links in all the descriptions we're
going to obviously be doing
a promo on it as well for a week so we
can win
a few things let's see okay all right
cool got one am i the [ __ ] for
telling my girl to step up her hygiene
i've been with this girl for three ish
years now and we've definitely been
comfortable with each other for a while
but lately
brackets the last year or so it seems
that days between showers are getting
farther and farther away
and she puts way less effort into
herself days between
showers oh yeah yeah i heard that i was
like he hasn't you've lost exaggeration
he has to be exactly she puts way less
effort into herself
when we see each other now i'm not now
i'm not a 10 out of 10
all the time either and certainly not
with covid i understand that there are
less things to get ready for
but i miss the days when we put effort
into looking and smelling nice for each
other
like you do when you first start dating
someone i gently approached this topic
the other day and jokingly said hey
babes
why don't you get dressed up for me
anymore she responded by saying that she
knows i love her
and she doesn't need to try hard anymore
what should i do
next and am i the [ __ ] for wanting
her to put
uh want her to be more put together
these are two completely different
questions because the
initial am i also making more effort
into hygiene and he's talking about
[ __ ]
not showering every day i know she's
saying
oh put more effort into dressing up for
me i think he's
he's lost i think
um yeah i think it's dating
through me yeah the shower and everyday
thing is crazy
days between showers and stuff like that
is that's unacceptable that's unex
that's unacceptable that's unacceptable
you don't have to ask anyone about that
no that's unacceptable
especially if you live together
unacceptable you need to be showering
at least once a day minimum requirement
that's what the bathroom's there for
bro that's wild to me
but hey ho i don't judge whatever in it
this kind of goes back to do you know
what this is reminds me of
is when you said in the group chat the
other day about
kind of like [ __ ] and stuff like
that
oh yeah how are you how you would
pattern like a [ __ ] with your partner
and stuff like that like so [ __ ] sorry
it's quite yourself for contents i up
for context i asked our group chat
um because some of our some of the
people in our group
have lived with or are living with their
current partners so i asked them
are you guys patting in a way to [ __ ] so
your girl doesn't see
or are you guys just [ __ ] do you
know what i mean so
yeah that's the context anyway and yeah
that this kind of
reminds me of that in terms of like
the way her response was like when he's
at our base like how comes you don't
like put effort and she was like
oh you love me like i know you love me
so i don't need to make an effort like
to me
that is blasphemy of course don't what
is this yeah
like what why would you not want to make
an effort for your partner
regardless if you know like it like it's
like a whole kind of like
it reminds me it makes me feel like oh
is this is this thing a scam
like did you put all this effort in the
beginning to scam me into loving
but there i like to think there's a
minimum standard that i would love to
keep basic requirements and again like i
don't want to grow up
i don't want to be 50 40 50 60
even 30 and whatever and just like how
to explain it
okay perfect example there is a podcast
that i listen to right
there's a husband and wife podcast
that's it two comedians they're both
comedians husband and wife
and stuff like that but you can tell
they're so comfortable with each other
like they're [ __ ] like not necessarily
[ __ ] in front of each other but they're
there
there's no barriers between like [ __ ] in
and like farting and all that stuff
they'll [ __ ] in front of each other and
all this stuff like for me that is like
a no
no no no no no no it's a no-go bruv and
like the reason for that is not because
i don't want my partner to feel
comfortable around me or for me to feel
my
comfortable our own partner it's like i
can tell when you hear these two talk
you can tell that their sex life is
about the urge to have sex
not the urge to have sex with that
person they
they smash because they have to they
have urges do you know what i mean
they smash on a mechanical sense not in
an attraction sense like
she doesn't look at her husband and
think i can't wait to [ __ ] this guy
that's what i want my wife to look at me
and say um in 10 years from now
15 years from now 20 i was still wanting
to look at me and think i want to [ __ ]
this guy
and once you start breaking down levels
of like i'm comfortable to do like a
nasty smelly fart in front of her
or i'm just like [ __ ] in the toilet
and she can go in there and it stinks
and all this stuff and i'm not making
effort to just like hide the nasty [ __ ]
in my life
like or like i can shave my balls and
there's hair in this in the shower
all these things that just like you get
comf comfortable with your wife and
you're like oh yeah we just share
everything with each other and stuff
like that like oh
she loves me no matter what stuff like
that it's like i don't want my wife to
smash me
just because she has to smash someone
and i'm the closest person
you know what i mean i wanted her to
think bro i want to get dressed up
tonight
i want to like i wanna buy this new set
of light lingerie because like
i want us to get mad with it today yeah
not just because like
i'm horny we're just here yeah because
like i don't want it to look
obviously your your partner's always
gonna fancy other people yeah like
strangers or instagram or whatever
but like you don't i never want my wife
to like
look at me and think like and look at
someone else
yeah and just think ra like the things i
would do to this guy if i had the chance
mad and then look at me and think what's
going on after doing it
yeah you know what i mean because as
soon as my i tell you like as soon as
my wife is comfortable fighting in front
of me
i promise you now she could never send
me a nude and get me
aroused does that make sense yeah
because you could never send me a
yeah yeah i know what you mean
there's nothing endearing about you
anymore i've seen you at your
worst there's your worst and then
there's fighting in front of me yeah
especially if it stinks in that and i'm
just like so if you're out here just not
taking
showers that's a whole different ball
game not taking showers
brushing your teeth cause like if i
think i don't even usually brush her
teeth today
and your excuse is because i love you
and now you don't need to make an effort
i'm like
you could never from i have to tell the
street you do realize you can never send
me a nude anymore
and me expect me to care because i just
don't
and i never will again um so long story
short is he the answer i don't think
he's an [ __ ] in the slightest i don't
think he's an [ __ ] brother you're
trying to keep your relationship at a
certain level
you're trying to keep it at the bare
minimum yeah you're trying to keep her
steady foundation
you're trying to keep your head above
water she's violating the whole thing
she is she's literally violent
bro i think it's at that point as well
was like if you want your um
and what did my message in the last year
or so this has been like you're in a bit
yeah
yeah yeah yeah like you need to bring
this back
up yeah and just be like yo if you if
you think this is going to last long
term
you have to you have to do that thing
man you have to take yourselves out of
the equation and be like
big man like no offense but
i want us to have a somewhat
enjoyable relationship yeah and you're
just walking around here stinking
you're showering you're not making an
effort i asked you why you're not
dressing up and you you
you didn't even think like oh maybe i
should dress up you're just like this is
why i don't dress up for you well why
would i do that why would i do that
because you love me you love me as i am
and you're basically saying you won't
dress up for me
but if we bake up tomorrow next month
that you have a date with you will dress
up
that's what you're basically telling me
that's what you're basically telling me
is that you won't dress up for me but if
we break up right now the next man that
you meet you'll definitely dress up
of course you'll take showers for you
you'll make sure you're long
shaved sleeves rags and if she's
showering i know she's she ain't shaving
and you ain't even shaving
we're done here we're done here
if you're not showering you're not
shaving if you're not shaving you're not
smashing it
bro we're not smashing it we're done
here we're done here we are done here
yo you're not that awesome man you need
to speak to her again and then
ask her if we broke up today what you're
going to do because she's clearly going
to shower and look fresh
imagine you know what it's like i'll
tell you what it's like imagine someone
offering you a job for 100
a year and then it's the best job in the
world
and then three years in they're like
we're gonna start paying you 50k yeah
and you're like what why and you're like
well you know
you've been here a long time you're used
to the job it's not as much effort as it
was before
and you love this job like you love
coming here like i can see the joy in
your face every time you come you love
this job so why would we still pay you
100
we'll pay you 50. you still love the job
nah you'll quit me and hr would go
we'd go rounds would go round you're
going to quit
of course exactly exactly exactly in
relationship
you sold me on this amazing relationship
and then two years in you're
you're giving me a [ __ ] one you expected
me to be just as happy about it
dead a man said it's been a year now
that's a long time that's a long time i
would address it in the first week yeah
i know you would i would just in the
first week i know you were just jokes i
know you would
that's jokes all right but um yeah
that's right